what's up gq it's polo g and i'm going
undercover on the internet
it's actually me
[Music]
first up twitter
does polo g count as a [ __ ] rapper i
don't tweet lyrics but i just want to
know
i definitely don't count as a mumble
rapper real lyricist you feel me i got a
broad
message like a real story to tell every
time i speak post it
hey bro what's with y'all chicago and
the
times double lows and y'all names on
y'all jeremy 300 600
1300. i mean that's just how our blocks
made up
you could be any type of number on your
block and usually have
two zeros by so whether you're from the
north side south side west side
most times that's what people gonna go
by next
next up we got wikipedia
he has stated that american rapper lil
wayne and hip-hop icon tupac are his
biggest influences
he also grew up listening to gucci mane
as well as chicago rappers
like little dirk g herbal and chief
keith that's true
lil wayne anytime i get a record with
anybody i'm gonna try to be the best
person and with tupac i'm not scared to
speak on
current issues the artist is like little
dirk g herman chief
they gave me inspiration to like really
chase my dream
cement twitter polo capitalize
what chicago artist what the most or
inspires you the most
i can't really say because juice world
was my dog i rocked with him but
coming up the main artist that i ever
listened to was
g herbal younger chicago rappers i rock
with loromo right now
i rock a trench baby of course i feel
like them the next biggest stars
was the cartier the best purchase you
have made no
my ap was my best purchase that i ever
made it went up in value
it was like ninety thousand dollars now
fast forward time now it probably went
up a extra thirty thousand dollars so
that was my best purchase submit next up
we got
instagram
how much for a feature my feature price
varies
if i got somebody that i've been doing
business with that i'm locked in with
i'm willing to work with them on the
price but i just recently did a feature
not too long ago for 150 000
so i'm gonna keep going up on the price
for show because i take everything that
i do seriously so i know you're gonna
get a
converse out of me post it
who even is martin and gina if you don't
know who martin gina is you need a
culture check
next up we got cora
why does polo g call himself capilot
i get asked that a lot in chicago we
used to use that term a lot
like they not the chill person basically
like
basically the opposite of cheer how many
times has polo g
been to jail enough times to not want to
go back
next what does polo g mean
polo is my favorite clothing brand and g
and my name stand for my friend who
passed away
at 16. his name was gucci
next up we got reddit
we've all seen polo's new chain but he
hasn't said how much has worked
my guess is over 500k at least this is
the change they talk about my big 1300
chamber
nothing close to 500k was like 115 000.
i got it from waffle
jerry unlimited in atlanta posted
[Music]
how tall is he she's 5-2 but i refuse to
believe he's five nine
i'm actually hovering between six one
and six two
so i don't know where they got that i'm
fighting that
i was wondering if anyone knew of his
religious beliefs and if he is in any
way
interfering with the devil and
illuminati i definitely want to address
this because when i came
out with my goat chain people were
saying oh ho
illuminati and it was like something
like them near seeing as like
they was just believing that i'm at a
high point in my career because that's
the only time that they're going to
throw that at you apart
i definitely am a firm believer in god
i'm not really too religious i just
believe in a higher power
submit next up we got youtube
[Music]
why are songs short these days like at
least give me three minutes bruh damn
it's so fire though yeah i had a lot of
mixed reviews
on okay okay okay that was actually one
of my favorite songs because i hadn't
tapped
back into that side of me in a while a
lot of people were saying it was too
short a lot of people were saying go
back to melodic rap
[Music]
this is good but is he actually singing
with all that autotune live
i'm not actually a singer so i
definitely use auto-tune for that
segment post-it i see you got that ps5
on ig what's the first game you playing
my favorite game is 2k that's really the
only game i play i like to get back into
the retro games like i play grand theft
auto san andreas or something like that
next polo capilot did you write that
kobe versus trials and tribulations
before or after he passed
i actually wrote that verse after he
passed i was in miami
that's really freestyling it really just
came out organically i was really just
speaking on how i felt in that room
why they wishing death on polo g and all
levels you know tick tock
you know i don't really play with the
death thing i know in this day and age
trolling is a big thing and it's a lot
of kids who
don't come from our type of background
where we don't play like that because
death is so common
and they coming from a background where
that's not so common for them for
somebody to get killed or somebody that
died so they
take light or something like that and
where i come from we don't play
we're putting death by somebody name so
see something like that most times they
piss me off
why white girls i like polo i think so
much
oh no maybe it's my melanin
whose idea was it to put ghost stupid by
at polo capola on tick-tock songs finna
get ruined by it
a lot of people say tick-tock one song
but i feel like tick-tock
is really the reason a lot of songs can
blow up a lot of newer artists is
getting signed just off the strength of
how big the tick-tock song
is so tick-tock definitely helped go
stupid be a bigger song for me
next does polo g have a child
yeah i got a son my son one years old
he's gonna be two
july six and then extra money
do you prefer lyrical rap eminem
kendrick lamar j
cole joey badass or melodic rap juice
world
x polo g little tj roddy rich etc and
why
i prefer both i came up listening
to different type of styles of rap and
melodic rap just became the new wave of
the world and i definitely love that as
a way of
expressing yourself or how you feel but
i feel like
nobody in the rap industry rapping like
kendrick lamar
so i appreciate both styles around
post-it
polo g jack harlow and look he's 20 20
freshman cypher do you think polo g was
just like nah i'm not rhyming on that so
they were just like okay
we'll cut it that actually went the case
i actually wish i could have wrapped on
the beat because i had a hard ass burst
jack and he had been agreed on the beat
they was bapping up to it and i'm like
damn i guess i'll just freestyle
something
is polo really into it like that i know
he used to be talking
real heavy drills in his early music but
does he really be in the streets
or he just know people that is i mean no
i'm not
in the streets man i stay in california
i'm suburban now
hey thank y'all for the questions but
man i'm getting off the internet